- boy oh boy do we have an episode here
for you today
there's so much to talk about in so
little time wouldn't you agree
II love my beautiful co-host I choose to
disagree why would you disagree with
that
you're saying that we have nothing to
talk about and as much time as possible
that doesn't even make that Dan in and
Zack the team that could we like to
defer them as they could do it all they
make me look good well not always that
kind of bothers me
today's episode is sponsored by honey
and rink and I also have a very exciting
announcement let's hear it that there's
a new teddy fresh collection out live
right now teddy fresh calm daddy bear
with the eye patch and a look cute sweet
little baby bear teddy fresh two years
ago and this is basically me and D adore
ya [ __ ] I got an eyepatch and I seen
[ __ ] and who did that I'm wearing is a
collaboration with an artist that I
really like her name is ISA or gentle
thrills on Instagram so she made this
art and it's also on the t-shirt so let
me show you guys briefly what we've got
here the color-block quilt oh sorry
BIOS I'll show it on here they call it
buck quilted jacket the teddy fresh
teddy fresh Teddy fresh Teddy's fresh
Teddy fresh sweater for lack of a better
name
we've got more colors of the three panel
Lily AK and black this is the hoodie
that ela was showing off lilac or luleå
I don't know probably lilac this is the
one that I had it's an dusty rose and
black right or die teddy bears on a bike
ride or die that's hard garment dyed
long-sleeve and then this is the one you
was showing I think this one is worthy
of getting a closer look at
you know Carmen died so it looks a
little kind of like washed out look at
those graphics Oh
it's Teddy in space okay Teddy first
calm and find those sucks and you know
we make the best socks in the game I'm
just you know I'm gonna I've said it
before I'm gonna say it again we make
the best socks in the game put it on
feel it on your foot and then talk to me
about it if you want to dispute it talk
to me after you've worn it okay that's
all I have to say about Teddy fresh
cotton I'm Teddy fresh calm Teddy fresh
gotta calm new collection at Teddy fresh
calm right ela no just in time for the
holidays too now let's do a summary of
our last episode was a somewhat hallmark
episode of the h3 podcast and there was
a lot of controversy surrounding it as
well we had shoenice after much
deliberation wondering should we have
should we not have him well it finally
happened and overall I have to say that
seeing the fallout of this interview
mate makes me think that it went pretty
well because we got like a good set like
at least a coherent isn't really even
the right word but I mean somewhat
presentable side of shoenice alright I
we finally understand where the name
comes from yeah I don't know if people
knew it I didn't know he's the nice
Shoei yeah his last name is chewy and he
thinks his family's not nice but he's
the nice he's the nice one who hate to
see what his brothers are like here we
go so let me let me show you guys kind
of what happened in the aftermath of
that interview but the reception in
general was people saying that it was
sad tragic entertaining but mostly sad
lots of sadness and I mean I'm right
there with them I yeah that guy's seen
some [ __ ] man he's hit his head a bunch
he's got brain damage he's been a he's
had been addicted to every like opiates
alcohol it sounds like his mom was a
drunk yeah I was like he lost his family
he's got no one
they are long yeah disowning anymore
something that dude was shooting from
like a motel room and he hung up
unexpectedly as they were coming to
apparently install a TV but I've never
heard of that happening at a motel have
you no but I never lived in a hotel I
don't know what that's like he's got to
get in there somehow I guess no this
video he uploaded what's this what's the
timeline when did he look like the next
day
well yeah any morning yes and it wasn't
an upload it was actually a livestream
right and it was short I don't know how
what order you want to tell this all in
but this was shortly after I started to
receive many emails from him ok so let
me give some context yeah he took this
video [ __ ] I guess way he took this down
after 2 hours and in that time he
changed the title five times the first
title was we troll to h3 h3 8 and then
the second one was h3 h3 podcast
aftermath they love me in parenthesis
then it took takes a turn Ethan from h3
h3 is a dick fourth one was h3 h3 and
Ethan is worse than Ted B what does Ted
be Ted Bundy right that that was my son
is that like his his poltergeist Ted
Bundy I guess that predates me and then
finally h3h3 destroys of lives for
monetary purposes and eventually so who
caught all this changes yeah how did you
catch all those because I only saw we
troll at age 3 in a variety of ways I
mean we were we found the video but then
people were also posting it to the
subreddit quite a bit and every time
they would post it it was getting posted
with a different title record yeah téa's
did it's a real teamwork with I should
before we watch this I should also show
you the amount of emails we've got yeah
alright the more like then got from him
well I was on CC on all of them
and but then I mean but there they
wrecked it I've been anything else we've
got just in the past let's see about a
month or so but this bolt yeah but if
you look from the 10th then he you got
for yesterday and then this week alone
looks like you got like 20 yeah it's
fantastic
[Music]
he replied let's watch the video so here
is his response to the interview a live
stream two of two minutes in direction I
present to you
shoenice
we did it guys we did it
moocher old a tree three what a loser
what a [ __ ] slob neck disrespects
people like me uh uh
I went even I went I will always want to
get J 3 H 3 cuz that's who I am
different I'm a legend and you got
trolled a deal with it I will never
support your channel or your legal you
just disrespect me what did I do
I don't understand what set him off I I
don't know what he trolled either I
thought we had a like these are great
questions that we got that he got us to
UM have him on and sympathize with him
even though he secretly hates us or he
hates us but he acted like I do believe
this is my question no okay no baby go
he's like is trying to create drama may
you think so
no then why would he be sending us
hateful emails because he wants us to
believe it hey you I mean it's a it's an
interesting theory he's not a dumb dumb
he's not stupid he just has a brain
damage there's a difference apparently
I've been snoring drain the wall day
let's continue the loser Ethan fold
you're a loser dude look into the eyes
of the people yeah you pick on your
[ __ ] podcast you ain't no better than
the scum on the bottom of your night
shoe this is such a joker memory cancer
like you Ethan in the YouTube world and
I'm so happy that I burned you and the
biggest troll ever
oh I Spit on your microphone your dogs
I won't spin on ela she's beautiful I'll
try by the way he always has reference
for you after you burned him on Twitter
because he wrote us some hate mail it
hate email like really vicious hate you
know and then at the end he said PS tell
ill I love her
I think she'll leave you for me someday
I just feel like your spirit is
further than yours you're straight-up
scum Ethan and you'll never ever ever
get better I need to until you shut your
trap and let people talk when you're
interviewing them he had a good night
that your buddy was loving where he told
me to he said Ethan you're always
interrupting people and everyone thought
that was like a great moment for sure
nice and so I think he's really running
with that mm-hmm trap and let people
talk when you're interviewing you ain't
nobody your eyebrows are just [ __ ]
like me I pretend not to blink and you
pretend like you can't stop moving your
eyebrows hence the pure scum Ethan and
I'm hope you I hope you see this video
I'm gonna go take a nap but before I do
kiss my ass [ __ ] kiss my ass Ethan
you're nothing eight three eight Street
ah shoenice for life I got you I got you
like a [ __ ]
scrub neck sick DISA toe so he just came
on election for two minutes I don't know
what I did I thought we had a good time
and not take a nap after that because
the emails continued what did I do to
deserve this shoe nice but this is the
thing with your scrub neck scrub neck
total scumbag I love how it goes come
back I really do like the way he talks
he's kind of eloquent in a weird way he
goes your total you're a total scam
Ethan like so such disappointment you're
a total scumbag Ethan
he was beautiful though
so are your feelings hurt no but this is
why I was worried to have Shu nice first
of all besides having him on I'm glad we
did the Skype interview but this was why
I was so worried to have him in the
studio cuz you all joked and laughed at
me about bringing him in and a
straitjacket like Hannibal Lecter but I
just I think he's too unpredictable his
moods and his personalities on day to
day he loves me and then I get like I
get really
bad vibes from him on other days so I
don't know I mean ultimately this is a
man and suffering there's a man in pain
I don't know do you think that what do
you think should we not be even be
broadcasting she oh nice content I do
think that it gives him joy in life that
he's at least because I mean he's
posting all the time on YouTube he's
he's craving attention and yeah and
views frankly an audience so I think
that ultimately it does make him very
happy to be included but at the same
time he is not well so what do you do
about that mm-hmm that's a good question
I think it's fine
because I mean obviously at least we can
keep an eye on him one we keep an eye on
him too he makes a little cameo money
three you know I feel like this was an
act like he's just it could be that that
could be till certainly could be he
erased the video though why would he
erase the video that's part of is a
method actor yes so dedicated let's see
we got comments on his video he was
responding to people good troll next
next one ever it took years he said this
this may be why he was angry he said
[ __ ] don't even offer me twenty
dollars for a bag of weed I know that
coming [ __ ] got paid of course referring
to Whitney Cummings our previous guest
who by the way did not get paid
shoenice we don't pay our guests but I'd
be happy to send you twenty bucks I
don't think anyone guess shows like this
that's not a thing well people usually
are coming on here to promote something
so if anything if anything I've heard of
the opposite where they'll pay to get on
a show definitely is the exposure yeah
and moreover I mean I think that
basically was our understanding with
Shue is that he wanted to come on
because he was rebuilding his channel
after it right the woman got deleted so
I mean at
at least at some point there was an
understanding that that was the benefit
of coming on and he didn't gotta but he
got a big subscriber boost from oh he
did oh he did yeah
did you change over 100k no hmm so why
you been striving for a long time you
think he was in the immediate after we
should buy some cameos from him and see
how those go you should buy a meal he
spoke he continues Ethan is the most
annoying dude with a microphone on
YouTube I always hated Ethan my greatest
role ever I think to troll you would
have have to have you pretended to like
me the whole time he never has changed
that soon Ethan has destroyed so many
YouTube channels but never touch mine
next time Ethan ela come on my [ __ ]
podcast there you have it folks thank
you nice up to his regular antics you
know I will say on a positive note I was
looking through Sean Isis old backlog
and I have to give it up to our boy shoe
I found this video and and Zach this is
gonna make you blush is gonna make you
feel insecure our boy shoe nice slams 20
ounces of mayonnaise in less than a
minute and I thought this was very
relevant to what we do on this show so
one shoot I say got we got a walk
basically I'm gonna bring back some of
the stunts that nobody could ever be me
at one of them was slamming mayonnaise
either way this is 20 ounces I'm gonna
put the tap back on I'm gonna skip ahead
to the a spoon for you add 20 ounces
back watch closely now in 24 hours
no I'll start look how he just takes it
down boy like that's that I ever seen
that's the best food dude that's
shoenice right there dude that's so
gross
he's just pouring it in his mouth and
like he's basically not even swallowing
it's just it's just pouring down his
throat a whole non-stop stream and I
like how it cleans up his like chin as
dude I mean what are you guys how are
you guys feeling to this I'm not
watching come on what I watched the
first 20 seconds and I've had enough all
his grunting come on you're not even
sporting it in your mouth the least you
could do is watch Zach are you feeling
insecure I mean all the crazy [ __ ] this
guy does it looks like you struggled the
most with his vanity like with the Half
Dome oh I think it's pretty inspiring to
be honest yeah I don't know what to say
I mean if he just keeps going and eating
crazy [ __ ] I think I think people will
always watch but he just he goes on all
these weird tangents of like shoenice
ASMR I mean I'm serious he did a
shoenice ASMR Channel he did like I mean
what is this thumbnail Twizzlers candy
eating h3 inspired no blinking you guys
know what this thumbnail is what is that
does anybody know is that him oh maybe
it is paper clipping maybe he was in a
newspaper my god he was like a handsome
young man he looks jacked well he was
yeah that does look like him actually
shoenice to whistlers candy eating h3
inspired no blinking you guys want to
watch this everyone shoot ice again well
basically I'll join your minotaurs miss
gatina
you guys get kid yeah there you go
he still hasn't blinked his eyes are
watery no looks like he's just chewing
on a organ cuz it's all been red and
bloody yeah okay so shoenice so I don't
know I mean I've I do I want to keep
including Shu nights in the in the
podcast I think he's an interesting
addition but ultimately I guess we'll
have to wait and see what are your
thoughts either I don't take it
seriously when he liked that stream and
those emails but I don't know hard to
say like that take some there was lots
of memes on the subreddit regarding I
feel like when we saw him during the
interview that was the real him right I
hope so I think if anything that that
being mean is the acting she nice is at
home like finally somebody understands
me he's getting deeper and deeper in
love with you you know but he claims he
trolled to you guys how did he control
you Adam unclear on I guess the troll is
that he hates us anybody yeah that he
secretly hates us but he didn't say it
but then why wouldn't he just say it
when he was on the podcast right that
would be a troll of yeah in the end he
put up us well it wasn't live so he
really couldn't troll us if it was live
he could like put up a sign that said
like some awful something awful I don't
know could show his dick it was live
there was meme reactions of course on
the subreddit reddit.com SAR slash HDTV
productions this is a picture of Ian
looking revolted me during the shoenice
interview this was my favorite YouTube
since these little surveys on videos
what did you think of this video it's
the shoenice episode please tell us why
it says calming and life-changing I love
that like they even have life change
yeah life can't think of one YouTube
changing except the shoenice podcast
these things and this episode too is
life-changing
Theodore last time Ethan upload on the
faint gentle baby Yoda
Theodore now really it's been like five
months shoenice on the podcast fans
ethan trying to salvage the episode h3
starter pack chomp chomp slurp munch ela
I'm over it dan do we have chips sorry
to interrupt
Zach Arby's yes Ethan I gotta pee so bad
kawaii F shredder and Alfredo there was
a special moment in that last episode
with shredder and Alfredo fighting in
the back of the the couch I didn't see
it but I heard it was very cute they do
do that all the time Ethan tries to
understand why shoenice is laughing
uncontrollably shoenice it you wouldn't
get it it's like - so what keeps you up
at night me the picture is nice dying on
the Reese's that was like I think it's
farcical I am so that was one of the
best look at that face
somebody wants to know what how Oliver
tree is been breeding with little
chickens because they have bold cuts
that really beautiful bowl cut this this
one I'm gonna need your guys's help to
figure this one um this one was on our
subreddit with 12,000 points and as far
as I can tell it's not related at all to
h3 h3 and I frankly don't even
understand what's so appealing about it
never forget when Akon performed in
Africa and didn't want to get a bowl
it's just him in a you know a bubble
he's in a bubble and he's getting likes
crowd surfing in a bubble and they have
any context I I got no clue this had
12,000 points I looked it up this
happened in 2014 it's not even like a
recent occurrence I mean it's funny it's
funny but it just I don't know if it's
12,000 up votes funny but and also how
did he even get like the first hundred
because it's just what so I mean
irrelevant
but wait is that a true story I don't
think they get Ebola
he's just performing I've seen other
artists do that bubble thing it's just
they just do it for fun
I would assume that people in the
audience do not have Ebola hope that
would be it that would be bad
well there you have it that wow there's
more there's a whole nother folder it
this I don't have this article is real
but what do you got there EULA
confirming that he did that he said
specifically because he didn't want to
get Ebola yeah I don't think that even
makes sense because it's not a closed
ecosystem unless he would run out of
oxygen I come performed in a bubble
Africa to avoid contracting Ebola but
still what's the relevance it's you know
despite being born in st. Louis Akon
considers Africa to be his home so when
he performs in large outdoor spaces I
feel like this is not this campus I see
I see a few articles for that one
debunking that though I can't imagine
like even if that was just aa process
there's no way he would give an
interview like yeah I just I'm doing
this so I don't yeah this article that I
found it has links to other artists
doing the same thing oh not in Africa is
there anything in the comments about
wises here no I don't have the thread
why did everyone why was it run okay
with that being there and I didn't erase
it either cuz like you know I don't want
to rain on people's parade it was
obviously performing so well yeah I had
the same experience I saw it when I had
like 9,000 of folks yeah I went to
remove it I'm like but I don't know I
hate when mods do that where it's like
something's blowing up and they're like
irrelevant yeah it's kind of like this
one really doesn't make sense anyway
there's more memes back me up here
guys the guys the comments that was when
we were talking about looking at
Instagram people had a curiosity in the
comments back from me a big time you
guys left me in the trench taking
grenades time to sleep yes it's a
disability mobility scooter I guess they
here's Ethan that's poor me Dan Zack and
kicking me while I'm down comments
coming to give me a hug oh yeah he'll is
giving actually kicking me sugar girls
one there I wipe my ass with soap Zack
rest again whatever so this is some kind
of should we move on I feel like you
seem to get really dull so in the
comments on that thread they were just
talking about it there's no nobody
acknowledged that it's on our subreddit
how many points does it up now it's
almost 13 okay
it really doesn't have that many
comments for how many it's just bizarre
all right let's move on barely gotten
through this episode like I got out of
the [ __ ] that talking about for example
McDonald's fights we got to set the
record straight we've been giving
Popeyes a lot of [ __ ] for we've been
saying oh they're so violent well Dan of
course the devil's advocate came out the
Woodworks is like well actually people
fight at McDonald's too
it's true now for I have to say you
didn't really change my mind that
Popeyes isn't the most violent because
these you there's like four clips here
over like decades I've got 10 there's a
subreddit dedicated of Popeyes violence
in the last two weeks that's fair but I
do want to point out i those i found
that in all of like five minutes of
looking like that's how easy it was but
not
that's probably mcdonalds fights because
the papa power
violinist [ __ ] the popular thing is new
so this one's actually too violent to
show but it's in a McDonald's and
there's a quite a few of them on our
actual there's actually a hundred people
and I'm wondering why is there so many
people McDonald's it's like a total
street brawl
inside McDonald's with the real cube
this one is the guy who pulls out a red
yeah yeah and then and then somebody
I'll show the raccoon part it's just
yeah it is very violent areas see here
I'll just show you guys the part with
the raccoon but you can see look how
many people are McDonald's what the hell
I've seen remember in New York the
McDonald's was always like that
packed hmm I guess you're right yeah if
it's in like a really
urban play yeah but even that damn man
how does so many people get in a fight
at McDonald's anyway homie on the Left
cruises in without some kind of any
sharing I wish I could show this to guys
but it's honestly too violent to even
entitle man gets punched that that ones
honestly just too violent to see they're
not that oh so these are pretty violent
yeah the only one that I think we could
watch was the regular day at McDonald's
which I did enjoy this one let's enjoy
this one together shall we
they're just throwing like a french fry
tray at each other back and forth
it's also
they're not fighting they're just the
rowing of like french fry tray at each
other so I pick those french fries buns
everywhere it's pay off it's just it's
just one [ __ ] week one worker and one
get off we're having like ultimate PD
yeah just do another tray on a Mac like
ten employers proffered somebody will be
better at a fish with Popeye dan you
can't talk Popeye Samoa stabbed to death
there I mean you're skipping some of
these no the next one is a guy gets
punched through a [ __ ] glass yeah
that one was intense
here I'll play it so that you got a hit
here just the audio alone so I'll
describe what's happening so apparently
the the employ the McDonald's employee
was starting beef with with this guy and
the guy throws him through a window
though McDonald's yeah the guy actually
pretty great like this guy thinks he can
take him and he starts pulling as he
tries to push him and he realized - he's
way out of his league like watch he
doesn't even move in then he goes for
his hair he's just balling his hair
and now he just the roses asked to a
[ __ ] window
that was a clean knock out that was a
clean apparently nothing happened like
that maybe was ruled self-defense cuz
the other guy attacked him what if he
just got the work kept working at
McDonald's no not the employee though
but do you think he kept his job oh
that's a good question I would think he
would get fired for that so there you
have it then you got your I'm just
saying you like the new kid on the block
but this is all because of the sandwich
that we're seeing this this surge I know
McDonald's has been here for decades
people don't people who die over Matt
over over Big Macs
honestly hmm no you wouldn't he look oh
I just started well I just remembered I
was watching this documentary about the
CEO key it was really interesting on
Netflix
he's like started hot yoga and he was
just like raping all of his students
Bikram yoga yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's like the gnarliest dude it's really
interesting not funny
but it's funny cuz it's so shocking
because everyone's like dude every time
there's this guy who's like I'm the
Messiah and yeah the guy that you need
to listen to he's raping somebody every
time just know that going into anything
if there's this big personality he's got
all these followers all these
worshippers he's raping somebody there
[Music]
it's really interesting don't want to I
didn't get to finish it it's interesting
Allah said McMuffin and then that like
jumped in your head right that was like
your first thought yeah didn't know why
- with getting fat and then maybe that
somehow associated with yoga trying to
lose weight all right it's a break time
it is we'll be right back guys after
this commercial break
short quick entertaining funny hilarious
don't skip their surprises throughout
we'll be here take your time watch every
minute
go to link buy the [ __ ] that's there
teddy fresh calm in time for the
holidays see you guys in a minute
honey ha ha you know what honey does it
saves you money automatically on the
internet whenever you browse it's magic
it's literally magic now you know what's
great gifts on the holidays you know
it's not great overspending but you
don't have to with honey honey is a free
browser extension that automatically
finds the best promo codes whenever you
shop online 20,000 sites across the
internet including Amazon eBay
j.crew Sephora Expedia Target Best Buy
medica da doop doop a get a get a all
those stores and more here's for example
we were just browsing like we do
shopping like we do what was this a
opening ceremony ceremony BAM slam when
you go to the checkout and you click
checkout honey kicks into action scours
the web for the best coupon codes
available that's right and it's just
saved us $26 that we would have never
saved before it's so easy it's risk free
it's free you just install it in two
clicks about a being bada-boom Bob is
your uncle confirmed confirmed and
before you know it you're gonna be
saving money in places you never knew
that you were it's fantastic honey it's
over 10 million members with over a
billion dollars in savings what that
just grows every time we talk about
Lillian that's like how many McDonald's
hamburgers McDonald's is sold or they
probably crushed that number a while ago
when I was a kid I used to say a billion
I think they crushed that number
honey supports over 20,000 stores and
has over 100,000 five-star reviews on
the google chrome store
lightning if you're buying gifts this
holiday season then you need honey if
you're not you probably know someone who
is so do them a solid and tell them
about honey honey can help make sure
you're getting the best price for
whatever you're buying it's free to use
you install it in just two clicks get
honey for free at join honey calm slash
h3 one more time folks get that pen down
right well don't just do it in URL don't
even write it on paper
join honey calm / h3 lightning bolts
this season could be a whirlwind of
deliveries visitors and holiday
travelers so it's best to take your time
to keep your eye on the doorbell in the
house no matter when the holidays ours
because let's face it just because it's
Christmas and just because you can trust
Santa coming down your chimney you
cannot trust the people who are coming
and robbing everyone in your
neighborhood like what was happening to
us that's why I got a ring of security
around my house six ring floodlights
motion-activated sensors at any time
somebody stepped to my house whether it
was a coyote a raccoon or some drunk
dude casing our house which did happen
I get a motion-activated detector and
let's say some wise guy actually wants
to break into your house guess what
happens it saves a video to the cloud so
if some genius some masterminds in there
and trying to disconnect the internet
turn off the power it's too late I've
already got you sucker if you're in
Hawaii taking a vacation you still get
the notification and guess what else you
could do from the phone when you're
watching these burglars try to get in
your house or some scumbags doing
whatever they're doing you could blast
them with the siren you could talk to
him and say hey scumbag I see you the
police are on the way well well they're
out of there
guaranteed or let's say that you're not
a cynical and afraid of the world as I
am it works great as a doorbell hello
who's there I could see you on my phone
hey can you leave the package yes sir I
can leave the package stop are you
having a dispute with FedEx because the
package wasn't there check ring Chuck
ring you'll see what happened did he
leave the package maybe he took it that
happens sometimes it's all on ring
they've also got the neighborhood app
you can see what everyone your
neighborhoods up to a suspicious
activity gossip whatever it is coyote
warnings police warnings everything it's
really good gossip and I love checking
it because the people there are crazy
but in a good way super entertaining way
it's like Facebook on crack and
everybody's anonymous too so it's
awesome and they're all in your
neighborhood it's sewed up as a listener
you have a special holiday offer on a
ring starter kit available right now
with a ring video doorbell too and
motion-activated flood cam the starter
kit has everything you need to build a
ring of security around your home no
matter what this holiday season brings
with the ring you're always home just go
to ring
/h 3 it that's I got the burp
that's ring comm /h 3 additional terms
may apply we are back we are back back
back back dan just fat shamed me oh wow
how dare you
I didn't we're ordering veggie grill
I've been so good I've been losing
weight people everybody's telling me
that I look skinnier I do think you're
losing weight well I've been vegetarian
for two weeks but on the feeding window
for a month I think I really started
losing it when I went vegetarian
interesting but I like being a
vegetarian but anyway we're all done
from veggie girl for everybody and Dan
goes I ordered the impossible burger the
mondo nachos and the Far East Bowl
because I couldn't decide what I wanted
and then goes Wow
dude really [ __ ] you Dan bro you don't
know me I want a feeding window my
window is open you're characterizing it
that you couldn't decide wow that's not
that's why I got all three that's the
thing we sometimes we like to get backup
options backup if you don't like
something it happens to me so many times
well order food and then I don't like it
and then I'm just starving the backup
option is real you don't know anything
about me Dan you don't know what my
eating habits are like and by a way must
I remind you that the feeling window is
currently open on when it's closed
there's no food what Eva said makes
sense but you you said you got the
burger last time and it didn't do it for
you
yes on you so right so don't have
anything you would not like but I think
if french fries my dad had a friend
though his name was mondo what's his
last name nacho mondo is that an Israeli
name it's the weird one Israel it's
weird
maybe must be a NIC shirt for Armando I
don't think there's not an ID on't know
that one Hispanic person actually you
had a Hispanic
cousin true he's adopted right yeah but
Armando is not really a name you come
across in Israel no fair enough
well even if he's adopted his name's
probably like each mila what's his real
name
what's a classic is really named Alec
I'm not gonna be I mean dude
Cybertron oh I also have good news about
the weight loss pursuing that the bidet
I've been using them a day and I don't
wipe anymore don't use toilet paper I
caught you in action today we were
getting ready for the podcast and we
were late and I and I know that anything
was supposed to like be ready and I hear
all this water I thought likewise taking
a shower now
yeah how do I show this and then I
realize it's Debbie day I don't know if
I can't show this whole thing but
phenomena pian you know record me
without me knowing the water was so loud
yeah we can hear it but we didn't hear
Ethan's response because he talked over
according I thought we were just having
a laugh go violate it a little bit but
here's the thing and your brother raised
his points me and I thought it was smart
well how I was using the bidet before is
that I was wiping and then when I would
usually go for a baby wipe I will go for
the bidet he says when you wipe you're
basically just smearing [ __ ] all over
your [ __ ] if you go with the chunks
intact the bidet is more effective
because it just kind of cuz you're
basically painting your [ __ ]
right over this though well I agree made
me a little something
I agree but he was right he was right
and so I went and I sat on the bidet
like full chunks that's too gross I
agree it's disgusting but this you need
to hear
the thing about the bidet in our
bathroom is that you can you're facing
the wall so you're looking at the drain
you could see everything going down the
drain and you can see [ __ ] chunks going
down the tree this is not our bathroom
anymore it's your bathroom and I don't
even step in there ever since you're
using the B day well you have your own
bathroom I can't even walk into that
room I invited you to use it I'm
surprised you're so grossed out I don't
know it's just the whole earth what's
wrong with those [ __ ] today dude but
yeah there was [ __ ] I could see SH like
[ __ ] chunks it's [ __ ] crazy
and then I didn't actually ask me if I
want to see him in action well that was
after I was already I just wanted you to
see the posture that you don't want to
see it no I'm just gonna leave the door
open to watch but anyway I did that I
didn't wipe and I just sat and I let it
go obviously I'm not gonna go about my
day after that I need to make sure the
clean was efficient
I got a baby wipe afterwards and I went
in and it was clean man it was spotless
so the baby wipe I was a test that was a
just a test but it was spotless mm-hmm
it was pretty amazing man I didn't have
to put my hand in my [ __ ]
at all at any point during the poop
transaction exited my body and there was
no hand to ask that's the thing about
soaping the butthole I just don't I know
a lot of people voice their concern that
I'm that that's a common thing to do
with the voice the the soap in the bot
hole I just don't see the need to soap
the [ __ ] clean there's no purpose for
soaping the [ __ ] clean folks it's
better not to put your hand there
at all you're the one I can't believe
that you feel that way after you're the
one that's been saying for years now
that it's like you have to wipe like 50
times I'm never putting my hand in my
[ __ ] do you understand the baby wipe
it's go tween my hands but I'm never
dude I the baby wipes is between my hand
and
apparently the soap is between no that's
your bare hand on your bare [ __ ] that
[ __ ] just gave you can cause bear if
it's covered in soap from what I
understand you use the soap no that's
ridiculous you can't you can't just take
a bar so people said they use liquid
soap oh yeah that's what I'm saying
you can't take a bar soap and like just
hit your o-ring alright Zach no be
alright people say they use they use a
liquid soap okay most people are saying
these liquid soap is that or is that not
hor yeah we got many responses from
mostly European fans you know those
normal you know those little things that
like I use them a lot for Theodore's
bottles it's like a little thing it's
like a little metal hook with bristles
so you can get in tight places that's
what I use my [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying like a little hole and you got to
that's what I use
maybe too much you're laughing though I
am I said lady but I'm not sure that
it's too much I don't get the liquid
soap I just don't but regardless I
didn't wipe I exited clean no need to
[ __ ] soap my [ __ ] I shower every
day
I'll soap my [ __ ] at that point but I
don't need to touch my [ __ ] can we
just say less [ __ ] like butthole oh
ring just don't say it
oops exit poop chute lube it garage poop
the poop hangar the poop the poop Park
the poop coaster
so that I thought was interesting and
important information to share so with
that being said let's move it on cyber
truck what do you guys think about the
cyber trucks truck this is very device I
get it
this [ __ ] was honestly I wasn't sure if
it was a joke or not is this the truck
that they've been teasing yeah oh so
there's no pickup truck it's just the
cyber suit
oh I see why people are disappointed
because they want it was trying to say
man they all wanted a pickup truck but
they got this this is the pickup truck
but who said that that one is not coming
this is it well this is it I mean
they've got the truck bill for a year
and yeah the event so well let's take a
look let's order it and I like how long
it is so I was looking for some exciting
car you know and there it came just as I
was looking only a hundred bucks that's
that's crazy so if you get the tri-motor
it's seventy thousand dollars five
hundred mile range fourteen thousand
pounds towing capacity though like I
could tell you yeah that's like 3 mese I
think and 0 to 60 in 2.9 seconds I don't
know man it I like it I'll tell you why
I like it ok
it's different every truck on the road
looks the same so boring the cars today
are so boring they've got this electric
technology they could do all this crazy
[ __ ] I like the cyber truck I like it
that's what I said I like it I feel like
it no matter your budget there's not
that many interesting options to to go
with a car and you know I've heard a lot
of people saying that the the rednecks
or whatever you want to say that people
who are stereotypical truck drivers
wouldn't want this but I disagree this
is like a badass Humvee military-grade
vehicle that you can [ __ ] [ __ ] up in and
run all our hippies like Danone please I
don't think so I think that would have
been a good strategy no cuz it doesn't
look like a military vehicle at all
looks like a cyberpunk like
Eadie's sci-fi movie of the I like it
I'm in I appreciate their doing
something different I think people are
gonna learn to love it too you think
you're misunderstanding
Zack okay so Zack genuinely hates it I
don't actually hate it but I think that
the target demographic of who they would
want to sell this to is going to does
when they want to sell them what do you
like I think people are gonna want this
[ __ ] thing
III understand and appreciate the whole
it looks different it's a new aesthetic
most cars look the same this is striving
to do something new I think that's cool
absolutely but on a practical level this
is a terrible
it's electric first of all because it's
supposed to be a pickup truck no I'm
gonna buy a terrible pickup truck I'm
gonna buy this how do you know you could
probably remove the back so yeah because
that would make it a lot more useful
well it slides open but if you if you
pull it up the angles around the truck
bed you see how it slopes videos like if
this piece was gone and it was just an
open bed that would be cool or I think
yeah completely but they big more to the
problem they must have that option
available you know to my car isn't gonna
come out for a few years so they might
end up yeah changing it yeah I think you
should be able to have the option to
include this piece or not because if you
remove this and you have really have a
badass I want that piece you want Eva
wants then it looks like a DeLorean SUV
okay like a Back to the Future as
everybody agrees that Laurie is the
coolest [ __ ] car ever whoa
but like it looks like a concept car
like it looks unfinished
I mean someone had a great finish to me
you know this episode of Simpsons where
Homer got the designer that's what
everybody's comparing it to Homer
Simpson car you know that episode EULA
Helmer find out he has a twin brother
who's like a prolific car maker and then
he lets Homer make a car and it takes
the company classics yeah that's
basically you on lost its beholder that
being said I will buy this car here
this was funny they were saying that
it's got a miniature boat windows and
this guy threw like a softball man he
didn't wind up you could tell but I
don't care about that that's something
they can work on well I don't know how
they [ __ ] up how did they oh he threw
it again and it broke let's go down on
this now okay this guy's hating by the
way whose Twitter feed on he barely
threw it he loved it do a demo you
better goddamn make sure so I wanna [ __ ]
that if you're gonna do this don't do it
at the top of the demo so that is just
sitting there for the next 45 that's
something that will be easy to fix them
a window ya know if you're dead know
using this in no write them until until
it comes out oh this is the man I traded
window yeah that's easy to fix dan why
are you hating on a window what it is
fine but Ian likes it oh yeah and what
do you think about it I mean I think
it's really cool there you go and uh he
decides what's cool I just like the the
fact that this conversation is happening
makes me like the car I like things that
make people talk and it's not boring
like every man that Kanye West exactly
yes after your easy this is impressive
though you have to admit
sledgehammer stainless steel one more
time now why really wind up the people
not audience or such fanboys whoa if you
get like a pain on that like they put
paint a black color white one it's gonna
[ __ ] up the pain yeah but I think that's
like it's supposed to come with them
yeah I think it's supposed to come all
[ __ ] like rough metal I like the
rough metal I do too
yeah there's homework because I was
looking you know our conversation about
vintage cars I'm just looking for
something exciting and but when I keep
looking at when I kept looking into
those old cars everything that comes
with it it's gonna be such a headache
like going to a gas station example and
then we'll that's the Lisa words fixing
it making sure it works all the time
okay that is like no oh look at that
mutt that bike dude wait wait yeah it
was open there yeah was open Dan
no it's not the top that opens it's the
side panels you see how it comes up on
the side I'm gonna keep it
don't move what do you mean like on the
truck bed it keeps moving Danny now a
normal truck bed it's like flat but this
has the triangular piece that's going up
on the side well that's it so you can't
easily load it from the side which is so
like I feel like that probably they
probably would make that so you could
fall they could address that I see what
you're saying though but most people
voted from the back No yeah I'm just not
a truck you but knowing their cars it's
all about function so yeah they'll
figure it I feel like that would be the
fact I when they revealed it I thought
this thing was about to come out I've
since seen that this is not gonna be out
for another two years it's probably
gonna change significantly especially
since it got quite a bit of backlash not
real I mean it was trending number one
and trending in the world like everybody
what do you think
I mean talking about it sure hello let's
split I saw people loving it and I saw
people hating it I agree that a lot of
people are liking it I just I wonder how
many people that actually buy and use
pickup trucks are the ones well I am
going to put a deposit so it's got a
hundred on it it's only a hundred
reserve little scam on fit bucks like
that's that you'll never get this here's
the thing too is the whole cool thing
about the Tesla's originally is that
they made it kind of like a sports car
right and it and it sold a lot of people
that were iffy on electric cars I'm like
it made electric cars sexy and now they
make this pickup truck and you'd think
they'd want to do the same thing for
pickup truck drivers which you know or
like farmers or workers and those kind
of people but people like big [ __ ]
trucks they put nuts on the back you
know what I mean it's like [ __ ] you
truck I could be wrong but I just don't
think that that mountaintop and call it
a day have you seen the let's talk about
the people that are here in the room
that are going to buy it I mean I think
would not want a truck how about that
right I mean it could yeah I think Dan I
think we like a truck I think in LA
you'll see a lot of goobers in it but I
agree in the country I don't know I
don't know if people in the Midwest are
gonna be interested in this that's all
I'm fine I think they might so fortunate
because those people think that electric
cars are stupid and I it would have been
cool if they have made something that
could sell those people on an electric
car and I don't think this is gonna sell
him it did tank I was the stock is not
doing so hot today
actually buy the diff can get a 30 day
honestly today might be the day to pick
up some Tesla season are misleading but
you know they probably were aware of
that and they thought well if we just
make a normal pickup truck
I think people aren't gonna want to
compare we have to do something
different something revolutionary we
need to take the pickup truck and send
it tomorrow
take it back senator senator to the
center of the universe
Elon Musk it up forget about it but some
armored doors and windows on it and then
all of a sudden you know they got this
roadster coming out yeah if they have
made the Roadster look like that like a
sick like a tease but futuristic version
of like a DeLorean or whatever I'd be
totally awesome this is just a shitty
design for a pickup truck the roadster
well this one does start at 40,000
though 40,000 that's incorrect I did
some compare it's okay it what surprises
me electric it's electric yeah but the
towing capacity for an equivalent priced
you know traditional combustion engine
pickup truck it's not very good how much
do you pay on Gaston hmm
sure but I'm just talking you know again
this is people that actually use their
trucks for work so if you're towing
stuff and you need to tow something
really heavy well it this isn't
necessarily the best option either
I guess it's it's yeah that's true but
it is electric that is a big thing and
the one that goes I mean one does go 500
miles or something on a single charge
that's pretty that's what they say I
mean right now the biggest better they
have goes you know 370 mm but this
doesn't come out for two years so
they're like they did that on the on the
Roadster - they're like this will have a
thousand mile charge it's like yeah
where's the thousand mile charge dude
but you know I have to admit when I
first saw this I I mean I'm still not
100% convinced that this is a real car I
mean so there you have it you love it
you hate it or you think it's okay but I
do take you seriously that she'll buy
this I am I believer you'll put the
adorn and it's like now I will probably
be cool but I just don't think that ELA
Kline was like who they had in mind
oh so maybe but I'd be I mean it could
be like you know in LA you see everyone
riding around those Mercedes G wagons
exactly it's gonna be exactly like that
but that's gonna be able to wrap I mean
that's good for them because that G
wagons are
successful car for Mercedes yeah but
that one is designed to be it's not
trying to be more that's a high beast
car right exact nobody tows anything in
that car right even though it does have
incredible capacity what do you know
it's that one that you like I was like I
like that car it was like I like that
car and I'm like yes it's pretty cool
let's check it out and I'm like dude
it's a hundred and seventy thousand
dollars yeah
but video and it gets like 50 billion is
what I hate is that that you're gonna
have to go to the gas station like once
every three days mileage on that thing
is insanely bad dude we don't go to the
gas station
I've been in a gas station in like three
years dude that's pretty sick yeah on
top of it's a really beautiful car too
but anyway that's here
I'm ride-or-die Elon Musk I'm Mustang
shout-out to heal on he's probably got a
huge one to like he's probably got a
huge one dude [ __ ] rock just looked up
the G Wagen has a 26 gallon tank for gas
that's [ __ ] insane what's the mileage
on the G Wagon yeah it's something it's
laughs 13 dude yeah 13 yeah I guess you
need that big tank with the kid 14 13
that's pretty bad actually it starts at
1:30 but you know with all the options
and [ __ ] it ends up well they make one
with a supercharged engine that's the G
63 oh well G 63 wagon so that one's
gonna have even worse mileage in 63
around 200 okay thing as [ __ ] though
what's the mileage on that dirty
[ __ ]
oh it's apparently has better mileage
fourteen one killing it for comparison
my Tesla has a hundred for comparison
wait 100 what like the equivalent oh em
gee yeah yeah pretty good yes I agree
Dan how many miles can you go and your
test
like 303 a mile the nuance now Cove 3
370 mines 3 years old for the new ones
now they upgraded the battery pretty
cool I'm not I'm not even a Tesla hater
I like them your card I'll cater I get
it of course awesome I just am NOT uh
not impressed by this thing but like you
said if you slap like a machine gun on
the back or something sure yeah
dude you just dropped that in Iraq see
people have already edited it to be like
a warthog from Halo it's pretty awesome
that's true I see the resemblance
well let's move it on we will follow
this story very closely we're gonna have
a hundred dollars invested so I'm gonna
hold his feet to the fire okay we got
news guys half life is happening they
released the trailer half-life 3 except
it's not three because valve is such an
[ __ ] they had to go back in time to
make a prequel the half-life 2 to avoid
making half-life 3 mm hmm because their
whole legacy is that they don't they
will never make a 3-game they've only
ever made up to twos and so they've gone
completely out of their way to avoid
making half-life 3 but goddamn it
there's a new game out half-life Alex
and this is NVR only the trailer is I
got so hype dude I mean dude oh this is
gonna be so intense I mean unless you've
played a modern VR system like vive I
mean it gets so intense in there I can't
even imagine I think I'm just gonna lose
my mind in this thing I don't know if
I'm gonna be able to complete the game
because I'm I think I'll have a heart
attack
okay afterwards seriously let's watch
the trailer
so you'll see the hand like that
the the valve penny called the index it
actually tracks your fingers and the
[ __ ] yeah good so what's the plan this
takes place between half-life and
half-life
I'm with you every step of the way
traffic to the mania don't worry it's
unloaded
it's unloaded now a plastic valve only
this is me so
Oh they've got dad they're gonna find
out what he knows and then they're gonna
kill us about the graphics I think it's
hard to get it it's hard to really get a
feel for it but I think it looks great
you have to appreciate that this is a 3d
world so it's even hard I know hard yeah
it's kind of hard until you see it that
way I guess but when you're rendering an
entire 3d world at the same time it's
even more difficult to make it in a way
that runs smoothly because there's so
much more going on you mean because of
that it's VR yeah there's just there's
more to process sure in a 3d world I
think the art direction looks great me
too
I'm like the I I'm a huge fan of the
half-life game so I mean this is crazy
though people are gonna like so you need
an empty room you need of index which
cost a thousand dollars you need like a
three thousand dollar gaming computer
people are gonna be mortgaging their
houses yeah you can't use it with with
like the oculus and the vive and stuff
yeah you can use it but those are
expensive vive yeah the windows mixed
reality oculus rift those are all
thousand-dollar
no no I think those are like two or
three hundred bucks only the index is
the one that's crazy the vibe was it
that Orlov five six I think it's come
way down in the last year or two
I hope the index is Wireless but it
tracks your fingers oh oh I can beat off
in with a virtual dick in Windows Dragon
by Marlies 100 so I guess yeah the vibe
was expensive March 2020 that is right
around the goddamn corner one of the top
comments was so fun and they go up
people used to laugh about gamers that
would buy a system for an exclusive just
for one game now people are buying
houses for half-life
you know I'm not gonna preorder it
though I'm gonna be honest with you guys
I'm gonna wait and I'm gonna see what's
the reception no one should ever
pre-order anything yeah but like I'm not
gonna be a day one buyer I'll be like a
one week buyer cuz I mean like the
difference because I want to make sure
it's a good game before I like [ __ ] up
my house and get like a view I don't
know that though or I mean every valve
game that's come out is always like the
best game of the century I remember when
the orange box came out everyone was
like dude this is stupid
it had the new half life it had portal
all my favorite stuff
it had like Team Fortress classic it was
so outrageous so maybe they'll do the
same thing here you know but have you
played the valve games in VR like they
had this one the little games you've
played them there yeah they're cool
there's one where you like they're all
inside kind of the half-life poor
universe mm-hmm have you played
everything you guys played those new
this came out like three years ago and
even then it's breathtaking yeah and by
far I've played a lot of VR games
because I have a vibe by far the best VR
I've ever experienced was what valve
made three years ago so you can bet your
ass this game is gonna be like nothing
anyone's ever played weeds yeah if we
should set it up here I like that idea
hang it up here what am I gonna do with
that come on we can do something with it
yeah you want to somehow make content
with it or you just want to share the
love just share there Thursday our love
she doesn't want you converting yeah I'm
like what are you getting at no I just
thought we have an extra room you know
here I want to play it I want to play it
I don't want their eye herpes dude
that's the thing I don't think you guys
have eye herpes by thank it was like a
hundred people Justin was saying at
gaming conventions where they pass
around
VR headsets they were spawning new
diseases like eye herpes
what cuz people kept taking off and
putting on their now goes you knows all
these crazy eye diseases going around
including eye herpes so there you have
it so be careful who you share your
headset with what else is there to say
about half-life Alex I wonder if like
like let's watch this trailer closely
really cuz I am I have some concern like
four for one I don't like VR when you
have to stand up and walk around
did we talk about this last time mm-hmm
it's got to be sitting but then here
they say the movement can be either
teleport shifting yeah zoom with point a
P like how are you or continuous how are
you going to teleport and half-wave like
so that doesn't make sense to me I
talked to a buddy of mine that has a VR
thing to ask him what that all meant and
I guess that is common in these kind of
first-person perspective I know but it's
not good I've played games like that
basically what happens is you like find
where you want to move and then you like
hit a trigger and you teleport right but
how the how is that gonna work in
half-life why it just doesn't feel right
like if you're being chased by creatures
you're gonna teleport away it's like
well they said that you can do full
control with the with like a thumb stick
yeah but when you can teleport why would
you use a thumb stick for the reason you
just said because the teleporting sucks
right I don't like it then I don't like
it and then here's another thing I'm
worried about is it that you wish that
you could like fully be walking around
no I think it should just be you have to
use one way or the other it should say
should decide what's the best way to do
it oh I see which is probably thumb
stick walking cuz that's probably the
way I would want to do it it's just that
son closest to the traditional way of
playing these kind of games so I see
that they built it for the hand fees in
the game for example like here
they're like moving [ __ ] out of the way
and grabbing ammo yeah I'm not gonna go
for school but a might is that gonna be
so tedious that I'm have to be like
hitting everything off the shelf looking
for ammo I mean to me that seems like
the biggest appeal gears can be doing
this the whole time not being every
really stupid boy you play but yeah but
it's just gonna be like the part at the
end of the trailer where she like move
stuff aside finds a single bullet that's
loaded and everything I mean that
concerns me Oh to me this was the
coolest part of the trailer this is the
part where I was like I'm [ __ ] sold it
looks cool but it concerns me you know
what I mean
it just depends on how well it's done
yeah and I mean they always do
everything especially because they've
waited this long to make it I feel like
they didn't have any pressure to release
it they would they wouldn't notice it
unless it was good I think they've been
working on this the whole time
I have friends who know people involved
who have told me years ago that they
were making a vr half-life yeah it's
been rumored for for a good long time
but I think they've they've probably
started and stopped it a dozen times at
this point and just now they finally
felt like hey this works this is good
let's go with it
mmm can't wait I was hyped this [ __ ]
up yep when I saw that ela raised a good
point too she likes to watch me play
video games so how is that gonna work
you can still see it on the screen you
see what it's not the same time not the
same is there not like an observed I
want him to get a second headset yeah
that's what I can be in there with me
dude I don't think alright that's that
what else czn is a thief a criminal and
a con did you get the did you get the
veggie grill down where yeah I just
ordered a good
you get everything I asked for
but wait what did you ask for again
mando nacho we're fun possible burger
what did everyone else get everybody
else got one item yeah and what did they
get either got a burger you get french
fries
now this nah brah I don't eat french
fries what I got her the roasted
broccoli and then the Far East Bowl
that's again yeah a super taco salad for
Zach here cheesesteak sandwich it's like
a Philly cheese can you throw one of
those in there for me as much for that
as ever all yeah Teddy fresh calm new
collection is out now czn is a thief and
a criminal and we have turned on czn
that's the turkish chef that we've been
in love with it let me show you what I'm
talking about now this is a video that
was on our document last week they don't
have time to get to his incredible
Chinese chef he he's on tick tock I've
been finding a lot of interesting
Chinese chefs on tick tock and the
reason they use tick tock is because
it's owned by China and they don't let
you use any other [ __ ] social medias
what do you really yes they can't use
any other they can't use Twitter they
can't use Facebook they can't use
Instagram they can't even use Google or
YouTube so they're like tick tock tick
tock Rachel yes the dog Oh pick dog on
Americans it was made by Americans it
was made by Americans they made the
voice tick tock Chinese people are not
very offended I feel like we can make
fun of the Chinese we love the Chinese
here at the HD podcast anyway this guy's
awesome he shouts he screams he does it
all and this video is incredible and
there's no audio
there's no audio why the [ __ ] isn't
there any [ __ ] audio audio what
do you are you hopeful to do is that
commuted it cuz there's music isn't that
[ __ ] music okay well just lose a lot
of the effectiveness without his
screaming they don't you want to risk it
well let me hear it for like a second
let's go oh okay turn it off
what do you think about that either that
sounds risky it's just like that boom
boom boom boom
maybe if we talk over it it won't get
claimed if we just kind of like yeah
here's a mob okay let me watch he goes
I'm just I'm imitating him because you
can't hear his voice okay now listen
wait up up up up here please voice well
do what he's talking now what it's music
here goes ready and good wait he that he
yells that's his shtick I'm not making
it up dude you come on you [ __ ] with
me
come on okay here let's find a moment
where before he talks it's a disaster
this is good [ __ ] we're on the back end
okay Sam you have the music on he said
I'm not how am I being Rachel I'm
literally saying what he said so I'll
just do the voice from okay no addicted
the tire off I put it on a rotisserie
I've got two rotisserie zon the tires it
stopped working the internet went out it
went out I think it just coming back
starting and stopping it so much what is
this
okay here we go I'm taking the tire off
I'm putting on a rotisserie I've two
rotisserie it's rotating now I put a
whole [ __ ] and
on it and two animals cook it more Shh
charcoal in anyway anyway he's turning
the wheels they're cooking over an open
flame it's pretty cool so how does this
work he's pushing the gas yeah someone's
in the car I think or you know yeah
something like that cruise control it's
lifted and now he's literally has a mop
look like boiled and he's just brushing
it with a [ __ ] motto epic look at
that the guy's such a legend he's just
pouring salt on it what do you say huh
yeah and he's cooking over an open flame
it's it's awesome he's the only one in
the middle of nowhere in a desert with
two carcasses so those will definitely
go to 100% waste and now he's sitting on
the desert floor just taking bites of a
huge animal that looks awful it looks
kind of good I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
sit here really awful those look like
good clean bites but so anyway that was
a video that was making the rounds that
everyone was a fan of and then all the
sudden look who posted a new video just
like what yesterday or the day before
yeah it was yesterday one day ago is
this one half music that's gonna [ __ ] us
up he usually does but I don't think yes
I talk anyways so it's fun so he pulls
up in a tractor and oh what's this he's
taking the wheels off here oh and what's
this he's putting a rotisserie on Oh
what's this he's putting on an open
flame down dad I got doesn't smile
though he yells oh what's this a giant
animal carcass that he's putting ketchup
on probably not catch other and it's
rotating on the wheel oh my god whoever
thought of that so what do you think
about czn ripping off re our friendly
yeah a little bit of a problem here the
fire is like going the other direction
did that fire it's totally out of
control even tries it out the fire is
like next to it it's not
and there I think it's indirect flame I
think that's what you want if I'm being
honest with you on that a guy had under
um he even stole the mop like he just a
big mop like a bush it's like a branch
and I don't know I'm over it you're
overseas yet well I just I don't know I
don't know to think about this I'm
alright that looks good
Shh looks so good I feel like that then
cook well I know and I looked cooked but
I liked the the Chinese guys video way
better
and there's another instance of him
ripping off this guy really yes man wait
what's the one where he built the hut
wait hold on hold the phone didn't we
discuss this there's one where czn no
but oh no it was the other guy who
cooked the whole camel yeah oh yes
seesee and didn't do that but another
turkish chef did write that we were
repulsed by he stabbed it with a rose so
look look who invented the can't cooking
a whole camel it's your boy roastmaster
chan that's his name on facebook this
one doesn't have music beautiful you see
II thought I was being racist but I want
you want to reflect on the fact that
that is actually what he's doing so well
yeah I don't think you should try to
imitate it because he's got a camel on a
mother effing crane dude he builds the
whole damn stage didn't I see it didn't
we see czn do this build the hut for fur
that's what I'm saying this was posted
November 7th Oh in that that's easy in
video way back oh you know that brand
community they all copy from each other
this guy seems legit
this one looks awful though like it
looks wrong what if there's a camel
carcass Oh gross yeah it's horrific I
mean it really is a dissipation and
there's no way anyone else is eating
this from Manila nor is it shouted might
be feeding a whole village after this or
something was how do you get a crane
okay goes out in the budget they lowered
it with the crane how long are the days
here so here they tip the crane out and
the camel is honestly just sport it
looks completely hard look at those yeah
I feel bad for that camel like just
taking bites oh [ __ ] I don't know about
this one dude
yeah there's no way he's gonna get that
camel meat to anyone but before it
spoils roast master Chen Chan excuse me
I don't like it what other videos roast
master Chang got improved
I don't like animal stuff it's for you
it is pretty gross now that orientation
to our now that I'm a vegetarian I want
to condemn meat eaters world but now
they've been a vegetarian for two weeks
here's another great one from roast
master Chen apparently wah wah
he's putting so much is a huge of
carcass and just putting so much herbs
on it dude like chunks of stuff like
what is going on this carcass bro it
just keep
and then what I don't know what the [ __ ]
that is I think it might just be snow
okay how's that work we're just an
absurd amount of oh maybe he's just
preserved keeping it cool yeah is this a
good one I'm not sure
oh he puts the whole carcass in like
deep fries it damn and then I'm just
doing this so we don't get claimed
anyway oh that's it I hate when they do
the cooking videos and then they don't
show the meth were on it okay here's an
ad from South Dakota they have a meth
epidemic and they wanted to raise
awareness so here you go
here get aware everybody it's called
meth we're on it I'm on it I'm on it too
so am I so am I
[Music]
meth is not someone else's problem it's
everyone in South Dakota's problem
and we need everyone to get on man
and that says meth we're on it for the
picture of South Dakota it's on URL
unethical people are gonna be expecting
something else URL
South Dakota has a meth epidemic experts
say that it's ravaging their their rural
state three hundred three thousand three
hundred sixty six people were arrested
last year because of meth and 13 people
died that doesn't seem that bad
13 deaths in the whole state barely
anybody lose their population in South
Dakota
eight hundred and eighty two thousand
some more more people in the San
Fernando Valley than there are in the
state of South Dakota thirteen dan I'm I
mean doesn't shock me three thousand I
wouldn't make go make a video called
meth we're on it well I don't my people
died and I'm anymore I'm making money
I'm making light it's obviously they
they have a big problem there come on
Ethan be sensitive is that the lowest
population state no North these numbers
are just statistics they're missing
faces empty chairs ela meth is an
epidemic and we all need to pay
attention meth we're on it in South
Dakota
twice as many teenagers 12 to 17 report
using meth that's outrageous a 12 year
old using meth that's the set of [ __ ]
between 14 and 18 the state saw a 200%
increase in people seeking treatment for
meth addiction meth is filling up jails
well that's that is just yeah I
shouldn't be straining a law enforcement
keeping the courts get ya daddy that's
just a war on drugs [ __ ] stop stop
charging drug users for crimes and
putting them in jail meth we're on it
they apparently spent five hundred
thousand dollars on that thoughts how
much five hundred thousand well
does it do anything they have a 1.4
million dollar budget - an advertising
agency behind the campaign I don't you
to buy a whole lot of meth for 1.4
million they'd [ __ ] us I mean we're
talking about it right it was it was
effective that's what the that's what
the governor said he said hey Twitter
the whole point of this ad was to raise
awareness so I think it's working okay
well he's got got a little bit of a
point there I mean I get the ad once you
see the video it makes a little bit more
sense but as a as a slogan meth we're on
well you know what's the most like a
billboards around that just say that cuz
we're on it
the most effective method like anti-meth
campaigns I've seen is like the before
and after yeah just show what I would
say would show months look show some
brutal crazy [ __ ] I mean meth definitely
ruins people's lives like look at some
of these this girl I mean look at that
yeah [ __ ] now this drug isn't just
odd mmm he's not good a life groaning
man look at that
sores on there oh that that's not from
meth that's like a Firebird maybe she
was in a meth fire but I think it's a
little misleading to say that's me looks
like well you are just looking at Google
Images it's not very not scientific very
curated no no is there anyone that looks
better on meth
I'm curious definitely not her oh Jesus
he doesn't look better on meth I'd like
to find someone that just looks bomb on
that let's see she looks pretty good on
that she got a little nicer hair style
what does she aged 50 years anyway meth
is a hell of a drug here this is a crazy
before now this is the dude from
Breaking Bad turned into uh what's his
name wish I wish I mean yes there you
have it
we're on it
we are on meth never tried meth knives
not out of math okay that's good don't
try it I denied a lot of drugs but meth
is not one of them soon all right that's
not a meth is like not of there's
nothing like recreation about meth it's
like you want to ruin your life yeah
it's not like let's have a fun afternoon
it's like you want to look you want to
be in a before and after photo yeah uh
[Music]
let it it it it it at that Tom you want
watch don't know there's too much Tom
made a really funny video bird but I
can't watch it because it's got music in
it I wanted to watch this Andrew yang
friend of the show presidential
candidate is coming back I'm proud to
announce on the a street podcast
December 20th the final episode of the
Year Andrew yang ladies and gentlemen
the future President of the United
States graces with a spreading will
grace us with his presence yet again and
is beautiful podcast studio we are the
best shown the most important easy
coming plus one where is that that's
unknown okay
I'm confirmed we will we are yet to see
that possible that his wife may be
joining him but I thought that'd be
great well yeah if she makes it
but anyway Andrew yet again during the
Democratic debates in my team had the
best answers was the most presidential
the smartest the slickest most confident
the most future forward-looking it's all
about Andrew yang everyone on this stage
is not talking about real [ __ ] the real
challenge is he is my president listen
what he says oh they go they took him by
surprise what would you say to Putin
but and ouyang take this if you in the
2020 election what would you say your
first call
well first I'd say I'm sorry I beat your
guy and second I would say the days of
meddling in American elections are over
and we will take any undermining of our
democratic processes as an act of
hostility and aggression yeah the
American people would back me on this we
know that they've found an underbelly
and they've been clawing at it and it's
made it so that we can't even trust our
own democracy the third thing I would
say is that we're going to live up to
our international commitments we're
going to recommit to our partnerships
and alliances including NATO and what's
going on I want to propose a new world
data organization like a WTO for data
because right now unfortunately we're
living in a world where data is the new
oil and we don't have our arms around it
these are the ways that will actually
get Russia to the table and make it so
they have to join the international
community and stop resisting appeals to
the world order oh I didn't sign up for
you let me see preach it he's talking
about data data and everyone there is
like what you mean the guy start reading
my password knowledge come on art yeah
he's he's dude he's on another level if
he doesn't get nominated it's because
the world ain't ready for yank but he's
young and I think he'll be back
they again didn't really fit your him
like by far the least amount of time
talking as I yeah but and once again
he's leaves the best the best impression
thank you Belov the yang I'm excited to
have him back on the 20th and I look
forward to that very much now as we come
oh did you want that you want to talk
about Jake Paul crying we have some time
here so I have some voice messages and
Jake Paul crying to his brothers loss
but I was like man who gives a [ __ ]
about Jake yeah no but he's such a whiny
[ __ ] he's like giving his brother [ __ ]
for losing and he's crying and his kid
he has ice cubes on his eye I actually
don't think that ice cube mean anything
is just to like make it less fluffy yeah
but why would you do that in a video
it's outrageous to what be walking
around doing a vlog and putting like he
was really trying to like make it like a
documentary of behind the scene like
Garth Brooks
yes making it raw and I watched it and
we watch the whole thing I did really
well now we're talking about so might as
well pulled up to me the worst part was
just how he kept accusing Logan's
trainer because apparently the trainer
said to Logan at one point it's okay if
you win or lose and he's very supportive
he can't get over the fact that he said
that because apparently he's like
preparing him for loss because he said
that you're following no I totally am i
think the trainer was was being the
trainer is clearly like what are you
talking about if he said that it was
probably at the end of the match though
it doesn't matter that's just a thing to
you just trying to be sweet yeah he's
just trying to be supportive like it you
made it this far you know at this point
this is already awesome so well just
listen a bitch-ass Elton John wannabe
what when actually Logan kept telling
you
like the Jill it's fine everything is
fine like don't come at the trainer what
do you want from him he was just being
such ado I couldn't believe it what the
well here watch watch just listen
why are you crying you weirdo
and then his homie
Logan's broadcast coast is like it's
good it's all good bro he's first of all
let me let me set the scene here he's
using music dramatic music in his own
video and he titled his video
Jake Paul cries backstage after Logan
Paul loses the ksi third-person but sad
music next to a [ __ ] power generator
yeah this is raw baby crying this he
won't stop talking about that one line
that the trainer said to him
listen the music boom so after the fight
I was super emotional I'm a very
passionate person and there's nothing
nothing more I hate to see then when my
family or someone that I love loses or
gets over by something and the whole
situation with like the ref Logan
getting two points taken away the whole
entire like training camp of emotion and
like everything just like started like
flood through me the dog's best part of
the video he was accusing the trainer of
being a yes-man
why are you blasting his your brother I
don't know him but it seems like someone
was actually well-known and I had yes
men around me I'm far from like I would
never do that I'm not here to be your
yes-man I was training Logan just
doesn't seem like this place to even
talk about this stuff I mean he's
clearly just trying to get views and it
works they got 5 million his views dude
his videos don't get views anymore I
mean I'm out like they used to just like
so he saw the opportunity to get some
views because before this I'm in like
less than a million you know Mom he gets
he gets views from time to time you know
but 5 million where do you want me to
skip did he do a wardrobe change to Jake
Paul do a wardrobe change oh I want to
hear this
let me go back did he you that's crazy
that he's back here confronting them
just for content for his channel like
bro this guy worked his ass off what do
you know about anything showing up like
Vanilla Ice and Logan keeps telling him
it's fine he let it go
show up tonight like we planned in
practice I just I did not think that the
culture is like what help bro you're
just performing the black
I'm just saying bro like stop being like
that's not what I'm saying I'm saying
stop being a yes-man not bro third round
he comes to me goes you're what you do I
heard that and the fight right around me
because I was the one making bread but I
never been take you such a tool
[Music]
hey Dave Sal keeps doing that but then
he keeps going back at it he's like I'm
not accusing you but why did you say one
point he says to him look at the end of
the day you're gonna go back to I don't
know where he's from let's say Florida
whatever you're gonna go back to Florida
but tomorrow I'm still a pole
this is the trashiest video ever because
it's like the fact that Logan lost is
bad news for me cuz I'm Jake Paul - yeah
Majan how much more revelant irrelevant
he'll be his dis marrying tanner mangu
made him even more of a douche
apparently than he already was yeah
maybe take it or leave it
but there's however many people in this
room and I'm the only one that's going
against the grain things the bog is
trying to think about it you said I
don't need to I need let's talk tomorrow
it doesn't matter I think you did great
I think you won the fight I think that
rap is about the court but he looks like
such a fool
such a douche seems like you so
disrespectful so disrespectful I mean
this is you know damn this is like
suicide forest levels of unawareness
runs in the family
this poor guy till you know he just
blitz him and recorded him and put it on
the guy never had an idea but he looks
good and Jake looks like a dumb
I feel like they're just I feel like
they just hate each other cuz they're on
camera and they're trying to look like
good brothers I think I think it's weird
because Logan handled the loss like
better than I did and and I don't know
if I don't know why I don't know I don't
know if that's a problem or something
that I should like try and fix her
whatever but I feel like I was there in
the ring with Logan and I love Logan
more than anyone in this world and so
Jake who titled this Jake Paul cry stage
after Logan Paul loses the ksi hashtag
Jake Paul hashtag team ten hashtag it's
everyday bro I didn't want to post this
he said get your free Team ten chain
right now though I got drip comm get
some merch fam text me I'm bored warning
please be warned under no circumstance
should any challenge of stunts or pranks
be attempted oh whatever
oh and at the bottom he stuffs keywords
this Jake Paul song Jake Paul pranks
Jake Paul scary vids many Jake Paul Jake
Paul Ouija board isn't this against
YouTube's Terms of Service to keep word
stuff at the bottom like that and then
more hashtag Jake this there's no class
yeah Jake is your brother like to undo
yeah how's your dad doing Jake he's in a
van by school somewhere oh the food's
here by guy everyone mm-hmm food is here
we have voice messages I'll save those
though if you guys want to leave a
message first call one 800 800 grilles
here I got mondo nachos burger and a Far
East Bowl far out did a the windows open
how long we've been going I had an hour
45 yeah hour 45 what do you think EULA I
think it's fine because we do have to
get back to little Theodore for his
night right now we can wrap it up
thank you guys love you Ethan do you
want them to comment anything you can't
even talk
it's the story of my life I don't know
what that means but um comment Ethan why
did you leave so soon without saying
goodbye
lost all respect perfect alright that it
that's it okay we'll see you next week
everybody don't he not have a problem
with food it's be careful he's right
behind saying he's happy
all right and we said there was
something else that could make Ethan as
happy as like the food makes him hmm
gotta keep searching yeah keep looking
looking for that happiness
okay very good weekend everyone this is
the allah klein reporting from the
gazebo we will meet you next week
[Music]